guys so here is example number one as you can see we are bullish right so you can see market structure
is bullish so right here what we have is a bc right so let me mark this out like that we have
a bc and now we are on our way to to create the d leg so
let's say hi and now this is the low of the b leg so we wait for price to take out the low
right here and what you're going to notice is if i draw out the fib you can see price came back
into the 0.79 level so now what we can do now is look for market structure shift and you can see
that price also took out this low so this could be a great sign okay so let's drop down to 15
minute time from and look for market structure shift and there we have our market structure shift
so let's mark out our autoblock which is the last or first candle of the fibregap or it could be a
continuous bearish candles before market structure shift but i like to use this method because that
is a refined autoblock so my entry would be here and i would target probably this high right here
so let's see how this plays out we get our entry
during the kills on ours so this entry was at eight right so that is a plus point
so let's see if we hit our take profit level
okay keeps on going and eventually it hits take profit level for 8.41 but i would take
one to two and i would go back home and enjoy my life so let me repeat this again right
okay so you see we have a bc price takes out this low right now if price takes out this low right and that is okay
we are only focusing on this low but however if if this low is taken out as well then you don't
have to worry because the abcd pattern is complete now okay so you then look for market structure
shift as i showed and yeah i guess that's pretty much it you look for market structure shift you
target these levels you don't necessarily necessarily have to target the highs you have you can take
partials along the way and you should okay um but yeah you see price the reasoning behind
this is let me give you the reasoning behind this so when the market structure is bullish right when
price wants to go higher what it's going to do is going to form a range so this it range right
so price is going to take out liquidity from the uh take out the buy side liquidity first
and then it's going to take out the sell side liquidity and then it's going to move to to its
original destination okay so when you are bullish you look for something like this okay you have a
purge on the buy side and then you have a purge on the sell side so now once price has taken
liquidity from both sides of the market then price is going to move in its original destination
okay so let me give you guys another example